the argument why don't you just wait
amounts to this why don't you just let
him cheat in one more election why not
let him cheat just one more time why not
let him have Ford help just one more
time that is what that argument amounts
to here with reaction Republican senator
from Georgia Doug Collins
oh I'm sorry they made the wrong
decision how are you congressman good to
see you still not happy with your
governor Kemp
understand okay he's a liar he's a
proven liar
we see that Nunez told the truth and the
congenital liar does what he does in
lies how does he get away with it and
now he's taking the entire Democratic
Party over the cliff with him well I
think this is the biggest mistake for a
while his lies only led himself down
that path I mean we've talked about it
before he can't spell truth much less
tell it today though he's crossing a
line he's taking his Democratic Party
over the cliff with his lies and the
interesting thing about it is and what
he just said just a minute ago should
scare everybody
because this president deserves much
better because this president is doing
what he's right when Adam Schiff is
saying is that fairness and justice are
at the epitome of saying back and
watching a clock and a calendar he's
saying that it doesn't matter anymore
about fairness and justice as long as we
get to do on the time frame we get to do
it on Adam Schiff has a lot to be
accountable for but now he's not only
hitching himself to it he's hitching the
entire Democratic caucus to that lie and
they will pay a price because this
president will be elected because he is
doing what the Americans want and that
is being proven true over and over again
he cannot keep lying about this because
the people are seeing through it and now
the Department of Justice is finally
starting to see it so we now know it's
all been confirmed that the unverifiable
Clinton bought and paid for dirty
Russian dossier basically was the entire
warrant now Schiff has the entire
Democratic caucus well first they just
eliminated bribery quid pro quo and an
extortion that just disappeared now
obstruction of justice and abuse of
power obstruction of justice because you
actually seek remedy in a court which is
actually allowed in the role of the
judiciary so the question is
where does this go well where it goes
this - we're gonna start off tomorrow
with these impeachment articles and
he'll tell you what's happening here
abuse of power is the most ambiguous
vague reference to an impeachment you
could ever have you can make it anything
you won't you don't like the president
got up in war red tie that's abuse of
power you don't like his Eric's wha-whoa
former presidential candidate wall well
said you don't can be impeached for
removing an ambassador I don't know what
do you want planetís living on but
that's not an impeachable offense but
abuse of power we'll give you that the
other issue is in obstruction of justice
obstruction of Congress after 72 days
give me a break
here's another problem though Sean and
you not hit on this yet this is the part
of where the committee on intelligence
actually tapped into phone records they
found phone records and they went at it
and found Nunez and Solomon and others
and they made somebody on their
committee do it you see the shell for
Goldman they wouldn't prove that
yesterday because they're wanting to
smear them they want to smear them Sean
this is what it's about
this is a drive by nothing but a smear
category because they had nothing else
in the chef's report that made sense so
what do they do
let's smear our colleagues we have
devolved so far in Congress right now
where Adam Schiff is leading such a
corrupt by investigation but he is up
she's hearing others he would actually
lead it impeachment do you stake the
Democrats will they vote and go forward
with this insanity yes because Democrats
fall in line when Nancy Pelosi snaps her
fingers all right
Doug Collins Thank You senator I'm sorry
they made a mistake Thank You
congressman